nowadays it's cool to hate on all the
big tech companies Apple overpriced
Google evil Facebook Lizard Man Amazon
bald man and Netflix well according to
the media they're already dead despite
having over 200 million remaining
subscribers some of the criticism that
these companies receive is perfectly
valid they do indeed collect user data
work to keep us addicted to mind numbing
content and some of them have a
horrendous workplace but while people
like to complain about these attributes
it's not like anyone is switching away
from these companies right I mean in
terms of Revenue all of these companies
are at all-time highs or near all-time
high levels and in terms of market cap
even with the stock market crash and
tons of layoffs all of these companies
are still worth hundreds of billions if
not brilliant but while these companies
are still performing extraordinarily
well there seems to be a new movement
within the tech industry that's also
thriving the and Thai big tech tech
industry most of these companies don't
create anything groundbreaking or
revolutionary they're usually just
rudimentary photo sharing emailing or
messaging services but that's okay
because their value proposition lies in
what they don't do DuckDuckGo doesn't
collect your browsing data signal
doesn't spy on your personal
conversations and be real doesn't
deserve you a constant stream of thirst
traps and Instagram thoughts given the
general distaste for big Tech products a
large number of people have embraced
these new platforms DuckDuckGo has 80
million users signal has 40 million
users and the be real has 47 million
users for a brief period of time be real
was even the most downloaded app on the
Apple App Store at this rate these
Services can surely be a viable
alternative to Big Tech right or at
least they should get a big Tech to
change some of their own policies and
tendencies but this is where the bad
news comes in just as fast as these apps
Rose in popularity they're also crashing
in popularity be real for example was
able to reach an impressive at 53
million installs but only a mere nine
percent of users have actually use the
app on a regular basis a similar story
can be seen with signal as well while
their total user can't keep soaring it
their daily active users was actually
down at 60 by the end of 2021. this
isn't stark contrast to Big tech
companies though people apparently
cannot stand their practices their user
bases are stronger than ever Google and
Facebook literally have monthly active
user accounts in the billions and it's
only expected to go up so here's why
anti-pictech companies are already
failing
people ditching these anti-big tech apps
may seem like a new trend but their
eventual demise can actually be traced
back to the roots of their success you
see most of these apps don't grow in a
very natural Manner and it's not like
they grow from one to two to five to ten
million users rather it's more like they
have 5 000 users one month and then 10
million the next month then back to 1
million a year after in other words much
of their popularity is due to some sort
of short-lived external surge take
signal for instance signal has actually
been out for nearly 10 years having been
launched in July of 2014 but most of you
probably didn't hear about signal up
until 2021 and that's no coincidence
much of Signal's popularity can be
attributed to a single tweet from Elon
Musk use signal the original tweet
itself didn't go viral and it only
garnered a few hundred thousand likes
but it did get the attention of the
media social media influencers and
eventually everyday people and if you're
you're not convinced that this tweet had
much of an impact just take a look at
cigno's monthly downloads as you can see
throughout 2020 signal was chilling at a
few million downloads per month suddenly
in the first quarter of 2021 though when
Elon made his tweet it exploded to 80
million downloads but within just one
more quarter signals downloads went back
to a slightly higher Baseline and by the
end of the year the majority of the
people who had joined in on this sudden
surge had already left a similar story
can be seen with people as well most of
us Associated be real with the 2022 but
the app actually launched at the start
of 2020. it wasn't until a brilliant
marketing effort in 2022 however that it
actually blew up you see signal figured
that most of their potential user base
was young adults and what's the easiest
way to get to these people well the
answer is college campuses in early 2022
be real started paying college students
to promote the app by writing about it
in the school newspaper hosting BBL
parties and sponsoring food as the app
gained popularity amongst college
campuses the mainstream media started
picking up on it and it really just
snowballed from there but at the end of
the day the app's entire user base could
be traced back to one successful
marketing campaign and as that marketing
campaign lost team so did the app the
same thing could be said about a
clubhouse as well in early 2021 when big
name players like Elon Musk jumped on
the platform went absolutely wild but
within just one year I mean just look at
the graph the reality is that while
people love to complain about big Tech
all day it's not until an external
Factor pushes them that they actually
try something new whether that be an
Elon Musk Tweed or a marketing campaign
but while such events are great at
creating Buzz around the service it
doesn't actually build a loyal user base
people aren't using BBL or Clubhouse for
the messaging functionality or the
chatting functionality or the social
media aspect really they don't use it
for any specific purpose other than some
celebrity is using it or everyone around
me is using it in other words for most
users these apps lack any real substance
and are usually built upon a pretty
Rocky foundation so as soon as that
external Factor starts to fade it so
does the app
most of these apps don't survive the
virality bust but even if they do that's
just the first step now these apps have
to live up to the promise of being
better than big Tech offerings after all
for many of them that's the entire pitch
be real is it not another social media
Network Robin Hood is Investing For All
and signal is the private WhatsApp
though ironically it was actually
created by one of whatsapp's Founders
the problem though is that it's
virtually impossible to stick to such
virtuosic Visions I mean think about
this at one point in time Facebook and
Google themselves were the anti-bigtick
players when Google launched Yahoo
Microsoft and AOL dominated the search
into browser scenes and by the time
Facebook launched Friendster and Myspace
were ginormous Also let's not forget
Google's entire slogan was don't be evil
but both of these companies eventually
turned to the quote-unquote dark side
why well I can assure you that it's not
because they want to do you really think
that Mark Zuckerberg wants a 22
favorability rating or that Google wants
to be known for invasive data collection
of course not the reason that these
companies turn to such means is because
that is literally the only way to do it
for free the only viable alternative is
to charge end users but if you want to
compete against free offerings from
nicknames you also have to offer your
services for free and that's where the
problem arises as an anti-big tech
company not only do you have to offer
your services for free to remain
competitive but you have to do it while
not engaging in it and you have to look
at the revenue avenues that the big tech
companies engage in this may work out
fine for the first few years when you
have momentum and a bunch of venture
capital but eventually you reach a
Crossroads at which point you realize
that you have a fundamental problem all
of those big Tech practices that your
app has disowned have led it to a dead
end take be real for instance the idea
up the app is that users share a simple
photo of themselves every day and that
they don't spend hours endlessly
scrolling through other people's photos
but bro how the hell are you gonna make
money when you're actively not just
encouraging but enabling your users to
use the app for as little time as
possible and then not collecting any
data on them let's just say that most of
these apps have a harsh reality check
when VC money dries up and they have to
continue paying for hundreds of servers
and the thousands of Engineers at this
point they only have two options turn to
the dark side and save the company or
continue pursuing their idealistic
fantasy and kill the company for obvious
reasons almost all founders and leaders
choose option 1 and before they know it
they've become the villain that they
sought to eliminate
virtually no company is able to survive
the virality bust and the funding crunch
but hypothetically let's say some
anti-big tech company manages to do this
the reality is that they're still
screwed it because if the virality nor
the funding together company the users
will because the service is
fundamentally flawed as it opposes human
psychology here's the thing while it's
easy to blame big tech companies for
everything that's wrong with their
platforms the truth is that much of
what's wrong with their platforms is us
do hey did that your Instagram and Tick
Tock feeds are always filled with thirst
traps or that your YouTube feed is
filled with clickbait titles that the
economy is ending as we know it
newsflash this is not because of big
tech companies these companies are not
committed to showing you any one thing
the only thing that they're committed to
is keeping you on the platform so the
only reason your feed is filled with
thoughts is because that's what you like
to see if you truly liked seeing
documentaries about kale and video
essays about steel fabrication that's
what these platforms would show you
trust me these social media platforms
have it down to our science and the
almighty algorithm is just audience
psychology but it turns out that you
don't like that you don't want to see
authentic photos of your friends you
want to see the highlight real because
that's what gives you something to long
for something to fantasize about well
this is terrible for your mental health
and it's also the most addictive and
most engaging so by virtue this also
means that an app that circulates
authentic photos is non-addictive and
non-engaging and though you may know
that this is better for your mental
health most people don't end up sticking
with this option it's the same reason
that most people gain back weight that
they lose from a diet and the white gyms
were packed in January while such apps
have a cool promise like improving your
mental health the reality is that
they're essentially a social media diet
and sooner or later most people stop
dieting
at the end of the day the Monument of
all of these anti-pictec companies isn't
surprising these companies are trying to
break the laws of physics by trying to
do it all they want to offer the best
parts of Google and Facebook without
paying the price and that's simply
impossible because nothing comes for
free if users aren't paying with money
they have to pay with their attention by
watching ads and by sacrificing their
privacy it's that simple that's how
businesses work they offer a service or
product or a price and if customers
aren't paying their business is simply
not viable but even if you somehow
figured out the business side of things
you'll be blocked by yet another law of
physics attention it cannot be created
or destroyed there is a limited amount
of attention out there and the people
like spending it on things that they
know they shouldn't be spending it on I
mean just think about it the biggest
restaurant in the world it isn't a salad
chain it's a burger joint the same thing
applies for Tech the biggest tech
companies will always be the ones that
feed into your negative Tendencies as
opposed to the ones that try to oppose
them and that's why these anti-big tech
companies are already failing would you
ever attempt to Big Tech detox comment
that down below also drop a like if you
would like to see more Tech oriented
business videos and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions are
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari Nazi guys on the next one
foreign
[Music]